[Music]
Wow and you're something where we can
take a break we're on the code black
crafty right now be honest how much time
do you actually spend over here I don't
know where it is I don't know and I
can't know where it is because if I know
where I actually err they're really good
you ate apples I do eat up laughs when I
was on the west wing
I did four years and never even knew
with the craft service table was because
I have a theory
I'm TV you're either getting bigger or
you're getting fitter okay but there's
no that what much people watch your
favorite shows the Lorenson tell you why
staying here come over here
cuz I read this beautiful thing here the
people the people of Los Angeles
declared okay the people of Los Angeles
the inside this big Cathedral there is
no person who is suffering shall be
without care that all night are sacred
and all and this is why no one else ever
comes to the grocer if I could go at it
it would for sure the prepackaged snap
for sure
and sorry one that I don't can you ask
him the question again without favorites
nice Thank You Ben over here do they
have leading man food and that's way the
cookie crumbles yeah they're not these
things they do the apple with peanut
butter on top of it and then they do
granola on top of that that come on
don't you guys love that thank you
ridiculous
tell em here Ella he's described
describe this healthy snack healthy
Apple healthy granola healthy peanut
butter doughnuts it's a place I try to
avoid it all costs if people are
watching New York Pizza
yeah cheeseburgers and honestly I love
like food that you find in a gas station
in a package that's been there forever I
think it's like the Midwestern Ohio boy
and me well you give me a fruit pie that
may or may not have been there for 20
years I am so down I feel like you would
not say no to a slim jim oh definitely
definitely not you kidding pretzel
nuggets that are filled with peanut
butters those are my nemesis I always go
for the pastry box I mean it's right
it's like right there yeah yeah oh I can
see that's why it's the cheese so I
don't I don't venture there very often I
still can't get anybody to join me at
lunch at the gym is that where you spend
your lunches at the gym every lunch
that's amazing it's it I just go crazy
otherwise this is the widest arrangement
of merging the stock crop is amazing
it's like a 7-eleven on wheels anything
first day on set he came up to me he was
like I can't believe food here and I was
like yeah but you've got too much stuff
in your pockets so if you spend your
lunch hour in the gym what are you
actually eating I just eat on the set
like I just what I put the food near the
bloody bloody bodies near the open
wounds it's really good for your
appetite this guy he was uninvited to
practice and it hit me this is the end
result so hey go to the other side thank
you thank you
in all seriousness know how to stop look
this is we here track your practice this
is after hours like it's so good I mean
like William Shatner like halfway
through the Star Trek round we had the
colonel like this is why this is why
that's why it happens
[Music]